la mission de l'eeie en ukraine se
rapproche de son objectif
les 14 membres du gendarme international
du nucléaire ont en tout cas passé la
ville de zappos ridja le temps de faire
un stop et de repartir pour traverser le
fleuve dniepr ou la centrale nucléaire
se trouve 60 km en aval est l'occasion
pour le directeur de l'agencé
internationale à l'énergie atomique de
repréciser le cadre de sa mission
mes missions sont des missions
techniques c'est une mission qui vise à
éviter un accident nucléaire est de
sécuriser cette centrale la plus grande
centrale nucléaire en europe
pour y parvenir la délégation doit
désormais traverser une zone contrôlée
par l'armée russe qui s'est emparée de
la centrale en mars dernier la durée de
la présence de l'eeie a sur place reste
incertaine raphaël grossit comme les
ukrainiens et l'onu espère une présence
permanente alors que les russes ont
évoqué une seule journée d'inspection
une inspection d'autant plus compliquée
que les échanges de tirs continus dans
la zone de part et d'autre de la ligne
de front les ukrainiens ont notamment
accuser les russes d'avoir bombardé la
mairie dernier godard la ville où se
situe la centrale moscou accuse de son
côté l'ukraine de viser les
installations nucléaires déjà
momentanément coupée du circuit
électrique ukrainien la semaine dernière
selon le ministère russe de la défense
un bâtiment de retraitement des déchets
radioactifs pourraient été touché mardi